[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
whatsa Prof hi Martin good day Walter hi
are you doing well yes I'm doing well
today thank you yeah we are here again
and we we've had an episode on current
events again
and it's time to we we were talking
about the
preparing in a time of war and rumors of
wars and looking forward to all of these
calamities that might hit us the signs
of the times yes but how do we prepare
it's an important thing yes so and how
do you make a decision as to what Banner
you want to stand under yeah and there's
requirements in the Bible that we have
to adhere to but before we do that it's
open with a word of
prayer our heavenly father thank you
thank you for all the blessings that you
bestow upon us and thank you for giving
us the opportunity to still do these
discussions we ask that you Enlighten
our minds also help through the
discussion and that everybody can get a
message that you want to bring out of
this in Jesus name amen
amen Martin there are so many people who
want to take an independent
stand it's like uh somebody's saying I'm
going to sit on the fence yes it's the
same actually yeah it's the same isn't
it or I'm not going to be part of any
movement because uh I just want to
belong to Christ
yeah
now didn't Jesus say in the time of
Jesus salvation is from the Jews
yes so there was a specific path that he
had
identified that doesn't mean that only
Jews were saved no there were namans
that were saved there were widows from
other regions that were saved there were
you know many that embraced
truth but it still was his purpose to
have a group yeah that was the harborer
of Truth yep had they perverted the
truth yes but if you pervert something
but you still have
it that means that people must discern
between what is the original truth and
what is a perverted
truth yeah so if I give you a parcel of
truth and you pervert it you still have
the truth yes you've just perverted it
it's like the Pharisees
when they were speaking Jesus said do as
they say not as they do yes so we're
going to talk about the final Gathering
and the sons and
HS and uh it's a it's a topic that gets
many people hot under the
collar I think we are quite renowned for
discussing things that get people hot
under the C col yes yes yes let's let's
continue to do
that Galatians
3 Christ has redeemed us from the curse
of the law being made a curse for us for
it is written cursed is everyone that
hangeth on a
tree you know if you if you look at the
depth of the Old Testament it's
absolutely amazing right how much depth
there is in it and uh the little details
even when it comes to judgments upon
people or what happened in the past how
it relates to the Plan of Salvation but
you see that's we've mentioned it many
times before you don't just read the Old
Testament as a historical book once you
get all the things that pertain unto
today as well and all the extra meanings
that the stories have it was the Gospel
in type yeah now he redeemed us from the
curse of the law it doesn't say he
redeemed us from the law if people will
only read that like it stands yes so the
the law condemmed us to death MH and
that curse Christ took upon
himself because it reads their cursed is
everyone that hangs on a
tree uh Colossians 2:14 blotting out the
handwriting of ordinances that was
against us which was contrary to us and
took it out of the way nailing it to the
cross
this verse is so often attributed to the
law when it is actually the ceremonial
law yeah because that was the
handwriting of ordinances and the
handwriting of ordinances is what Moses
wrote and it was placed beside the AR
yeah and it pointed to the death of
Christ it was the sacrificial system
with all its types and
ceremonies and by one sacrifice he has
forever made perfect therefore nailing
the ceremonial law to the Cross yeah or
for that matter tree but he didn't nail
the law The Ten Commandments to the
Cross because he says the law is Holy
just and good in another place it says
the law is perfect converting the soul
now why would you want to abrogate
something that is perfect yeah it's
stupidity and if God were to abrogate
his law the basis of his government then
he might as well abrogate himself
correct because then he has no more
Authority he has nothing more to say how
can he expect obedience if there is
nothing to
obey if you just work it through
logically how can you then say the law
is gone the law stands forever and ever
says the Bible Deuteronomy
21:23 his body shall not remain all
night upon the tree but Thou shalt in
any wise bury him that day for he that
is hanged is a cursed of God that thy
land be not defiled which the Lord thy
God giv thee for an inheritance what a
marvelous instruction and a prophecy yes
it's it's a prophecy was Jesus removed
that very day yes was he cursed of God
yes he took the curse that fell Upon Us
upon himself yeah because of the
transgression of the law he by his
stripes we are healed yeah now if he
could have done away with the law then
there would have been no transgression
because there would be no law to
transgress then he would not have to
have died if people would logically
think this through they would understand
the Plan of Salvation better it is
because the law is
immutable that he hung on that tree
otherwise you could have just come and
preached don't worry the I have come the
law is taken away was the devil thrown
out of Heaven yes were Adam and Eve
thrown out of the Garden of Eden yes
were the conditions attached to their
return yes the one they were thrown out
because of transgression and obedience
would bring them back all right
but only through faith in the Redeemer
the promised one the one that was not at
fault yes the one who said that he will
put
enmity between the seed of the devil and
the seed of the woman the
church Galatians 3: 29 and if ye be
Christ then ye are Abraham's seed and
hes according to the promise so who are
the hes according to the
promise they that are Abraham's seed and
therefore Christ so they that that obey
the law so if you are Christ then you
are Abraham's seed
okay so let's have a look at this little
word as and have just do a little bit of
a
contemplation as to what it means Romans
8:12 therefore brethren we are Debs not
to the flesh to live after the flesh for
if you live after the flesh you shall
die in other words if you
sin the wages of sin are death that's it
but if through the spirit do mortify the
Deeds of the body you shall live in
other words if you through the power of
the Holy Spirit correct your life you
will live yeah
for as many as are led by the spirit of
God they are the sons of God now in
another place it says it's in Acts
chapter
5 that you receive the Holy Spirit when
you obey God that's it I think we
actually did a a whole um WhatsApp Prof
on it you are the sons of God all right
so you receive this leading of the Holy
Spirit when you repent realize that you
are a transgressor of God's law ask God
to clean up your
act and then you become a Son of God
yeah for you have not received the
spirit of bondage again to fear but you
have received the spirit of adoption
whereby we cry Abba Father in other
words you are reconciled with
God the spirit itself bearing Witness
with our spirit that we are the children
of God and if children then hes AES of
God and Joint hes with
Christ if so be that we suffer with him
that we may also be glorified together
so M can you remove Christ out of this
equation no not at all he is the one
that helps you to become a Son of God
and Heir and he is the one that enables
you he is the one who makes it possible
again he is the perfect obedient ones I
have come to do thy
will oh my God right yeah thy law is
within my
heart so this is the character of Christ
so he the sinless one paid the price for
my
transgression and through his wounds I
can be healed but I have to appropriate
them by faith yeah okay and if I do that
I become an heir together with Christ
all right what was that first uh section
that we read the law
yes was a curse yes so you do away with
the law no you pay the price yeah God
paid the price for you MH and the law
could not be abrogated can you divorce
the law from The Plan of Salvation no
because then you divorce Christ from The
Plan of Salvation if there is no law
there's no transgression if there's no
transgression there's no need of of a
redeemer no need yeah so you cannot
divorce the law from The Plan of
Salvation and you cannot divorce Christ
the sinless one from the Plan of
Salvation yeah they go together and they
will remain together for all
eternity that's
it Romans
4:14 and if they which are of the law be
hes faith is made
void and the promise made of none effect
that's a pretty powerful
statement so if you say I am saved
because I keep the
law then you have disqualified yourself
from Heaven yeah now that obviously
means then According to some that you
must not keep the law Unfortunately they
go that route yes then they go that
route because they
divorce the union between Christ and
obedience right that's true because they
want you see you've got the works on the
one side and then the legalists on the
other side all right so let's just
rephrase this verse over here and say
that if you are a legalist and think you
can be saved through the by the law then
the Promise by faith is made of non
effect because faith is the substance of
things hoped for the evidence of Things
Not Seen whereas if you keep the law
everybody can see that you are keeping
the law yeah or if you pretend to keep
the law some may see the pretense as
keeping the law yes but somewhere down
the line that will fail that will fail
you cannot keep up if it's not true
repentance the reason and true
conviction the reason why you're keeping
the law it it won't keep up no won't and
if you be
Christ then you are Abraham seed and as
according to the promise that is a such
a powerful verse so the if there is a
very important little word it's a very
small little word but remove it and the
whole the whole story falls apart right
yeah so what is the prerequisite you
have to be Christ's in order to be
Abraham's
seed you know people would like to turn
that round and say but Christ is
Abraham's seed yes but before Abraham
was I am yeah so they they have they
can't they can't get their way but you
see also now that you mentioned that
word if it's small word um it's
interesting that the King James it
there's always either the if or should
yes but other translations sometimes go
and change it for instance John 3:16
where um God so loved the world that He
Sent His only begotten son and then the
King James says that everyone that
believeth in him should doesn't say
shall yes the other one say shall so
this if is in the same portion there's
an there's a requirement yes it's not
just a given yes there is a condition
there a condition all
right Hebrews 6 ver 17 we in God willing
more abundantly to show unto the hirs of
Promise the immutability of his counsel
confirming it by an oath
so this promise to be an heir is an
immutable immutable subject so God prom
promises it so it is established by an
oath yeah it is promised it is not
movable you can't move it right Hebrews
11:9 by faith he SED in the land of
promise as in a strange country dwelling
in Tabernacles with Isaac and Jacob the
hes with him of the same
promise why were Isaac and Jacob hes
because they were his literal indeed but
so was so was ishma yeah no why were
they hes of The Promise by their faith
because they believed and it was
accredited to them for
righteousness and uh if you take Jacob
how he wrestled with
God and how he said I will not let you
go lest you bless
me that is the way that you become air
so he had repentance for his
transgression
mhm and he embraced the one he was
wrestling with who was Christ and he
would not let him go yeah so he became
an
heir of the promise that's it but there
were sers and never received anything on
this Earth no not on the earth no but
the fortunately not because then we
would be both without
inheritance So This Promise extends to
eternal life right yeah that's that's
the real promise is with Christ I mean
that is such a privilege
yes all right so let's have a little bit
of a look at this book of Galatians it's
such a fascinating Story and there's so
many confusions what is he talking about
is he talking about the law of Ten
Commandments is he talking about the
ceremonial law where are we in this
divide what if he's talking about both
can be both and its context is has a lot
to play there yes but also when you
mentioned earlier that the ordinances
and the writings of Moses was next to
the ark and the moral law inside of the
Ark when Jesus nailed it to the cross it
does not mean that it was not worth
anything oh no it was the Plan of
Salvation in type so it he didn't
destroy it he just fulfilled it correct
so in Christ everything still exists he
is the antitypical
sacrifice so here's a quote from The
Acts of the
Apostles while taring at Corinth Paul
had cause for serious apprehension
concerning some of the churches already
established through the influence of
false teachers who had Arisen amongst
the Believers in Jerusalem
division heresy and sensualism it's
interesting that that one always comes
in as well right were rapidly gaining
ground amongst the Believers in
galatia these false teachers were
mingling Jewish Traditions with the
truths of the Gospel ignoring the
decisions of the general council at
Jerusalem they urged upon the Gentile
converts the observance of the
ceremonial law the sitation was critical
the evils that had been introduced
threatened speedily to destroy the
galatian
churches now
Martin mingling Jewish Traditions with
the truth of the Gospel That's History
mhm are the modern day people not
mingling human Traditions with the truth
of the
Gospel exactly the same we've got to
repeat oh well I think it's never never
changed it's just on a different level
right but it's the same
thing Paul was cut to the heart and his
soul was stirred by this open apostasy
on the part of those to whom he had
Faithfully taught the principles of the
Gospel he immediately wrote to the
deluded Believers exposing the false
theories that they had accepted and with
great severity rebuking those who were
departing from the
faith uh that brings to mind again the
modern situation mhm if you say
something then you are without love
that's what they say don't judge me
don't judge me but with great severity
he rebuked those that were departing
from the faith why because he didn't
care or because he was a hard task
master or because he cared because he
cared and that brings me also back to
people accuse us of not taking on the
apostasy in our own ranks
but we take on the
transgression we don't single out the
transgressor no if the shoe fits then
wear it it's so we are very vehemently
opposed to any apostasy correct but we
are not in the game of pointing out the
individual individual and you can see
unless unless it is a public sin that's
it that can be publicly rebuked for sure
but you can see this same was done by
Paul to the Galatians it was with
severity that he was rebuking them but
he didn't single out certain people no
there's no mention here of any of that
so after saluting the Galatians in the
words grace to you and peace from God
the father and from the Lord Jesus
Christ he addresses to them these words
of sharp Repro I Marvel that you are so
soon removed from him that called you
into the grace of Christ unto another
gospel
which is not another but there be some
that trouble you and would pervert the
gospel of Christ but though we or an
angel from heaven preach any other
gospel unto you than that which we have
preached unto you let him be a cursed
Paul's teaching had been in harmony with
the scriptures and the Holy Spirit had
witnessed to his labors therefore he
warned his Brethren not to listen to
anything that contradicted the truths he
had taught them and yet they would in
favor of their pet
theories rather get rid of Paul don't
they want to do it still today today
there are whole movements particularly
in our country that say you cannot
include the writings of Paul yeah
because it contradicts their favorite
dogmas
mhm of exclusiveness yeah yeah yeah so
the Apostle B the galatian Believers
consider carefully their first
experience in the Christian church oh
foolish Galatians he explained who has
Bewitched you that you should not obey
the truth before whose eyes Jesus Christ
has been evidently set forth crucified
amongst you this only would I learn of
you received ye the Spirit by The Works
of the law or by the hearing of
Faith are you so foolish having begun in
the spirit are you now made perfect by
the the flesh have you suffered so many
things in vain if it be yet in vain he
therefore that minister to you the
spirit and worketh miracles amongst you
does he it by The Works of the law or by
the hearing of Faith now
Martin God looked at you and saw your
beautiful
obedience and that is why he called you
into the ministry
right definitely not definitely not
right there we were in the world doing
our thing totally the opposite of what
he actually expects from you were a rave
DJ in the middle of the night and when
you in the middle of the night is quite
true yes and when you got too exhausted
your wife took
over and me I was an atheist cursing God
believing in evolution so I definitely
was not redeemed by The Works of the
law and neither were you right and so
neither is anyone else no on this planet
for all have sinned and fall short of
the glory of God so if you think that
you can be Redeemed by The Works of the
law then think again that's it there's
only faith in Jesus Christ that changes
it one Corinthians 123 wherefore I gave
you to understand that no man speaking
by the spirit of God
calls Jesus a
cursed and that no man can say that
Jesus is the
Lord but by the Holy Ghost so Martin if
you cannot say that Jesus is
Lord then you don't have the Holy
Spirit right now many people say Jesus
is Lord but they don't keep the law
yeah then then they also can't have the
Holy Spirit because acts chap 5 says the
holy spirit is given to them that obey
him yeah so did you have the Holy Spirit
no did I have the Holy Spirit when he
was always there knocking yes but I
didn't have him he wasn't the gift yet
you didn't accept him he was
a pricking instrument yeah and who was
kicking against the Pricks you and I and
Paul yeah and until he got a whack mhm
did you get a whack yes I also got a
whack got a few whacks okay so his Lord
is
curios what does that
mean well Thea defines it he to whom a
person or thing
belongs about which he has power of
deciding Master Lord the possessor and
disposer of a thing the owner one who
has control of the person the master so
it's the Sovereign the prince the chief
the emperor it's a title of Honor
expressive of respect and reverence with
which servants greet their Master this
title is given to God the Messiah it's
part of speech it's a noun it's
masculine it's not
transgender it doesn't have an identity
crisis no it doesn't identify as a cat
or anything else it's what it is so
Martin here is the Lord Jesus Christ
he's the owner he's the Creator he's the
owner by creation he's the owner by
Redemption he's he has repurchased
you and he's God and he's the
Messiah so if I say he is
Lord and He is the master then do I have
to to obey him yes
okay thus Paul arraigned the Believers
in galatia before the tribunal of their
own conscience and sought to arrest them
in their course relying on the power of
God to save and refusing to recognize
the doctrines of the apostate teachers
the Apostle endeavored to lead the
converts to see that they had been
grossly
deceived but that by returning to their
former faith in the gospel El they might
yet defeat the purpose of Satan he took
his position firmly on the side of Truth
and righteousness and his Supreme faith
and confidence in the message he bore
helped many whose Faith had failed to
return to their allegiance to the Savior
how different from Paul's manner of
writing to the Corinthian Church was the
course he pursued towards the Galatians
the former he rebuked with caution and
tenderness the latter with words of
unsparing reproof the Corinthians had
been overcome by
Temptation so it is necessary sometimes
to rebuke false gospels did it happen in
the Reformation oh for sure I mean what
was the Martin Luther's thesis all about
correct and here he was
addressing the traditions of men right
indulgences were purely a tradition of
men in order to pay for a a structure
that were they were erecting with
marvelous paintings on ceilings which
will one day come to North mhm and that
will bring you salvation Salvation yes
what nonsense and he rightly rebuked it
and he placed a lot of emphasis on
righteousness by faith rightly so yeah
does that make righteousness by faith
null and void no
no but
unfortunately people then veered to the
other side and placed more emphasis on
that than on obedience sounds like the
Galatians it's just like the
Galatians and so we we have the same
situation today packaged in a different
form yeah and
different let's say people churches like
the Corinthians and the Galatians do
things differently but both of it's in
apostasy yes so deceived by the
ingenious sis of teachers who presented
errors under the guise of Truth they had
become confused and bewildered to teach
them to distinguish the false from the
true called for caution and patience
harshness or injudicious haste on Paul's
part would have destroyed his influence
over many of those whom he longed to
help in the galatian churches open
unmasked error was supplanting the
Gospel
message Christ the true foundation of
the faith was virtually renounced for
the obsolete ceremonies of
Judaism if you take Catholicism today
don't they
absolutely negate salvation in
Christ completely there's no no
salvation in Christ everything is
through the sacraments through
ceremonies and through decrees yeah
nothing nothing has to do with Christ
he's not even in the
atonement the apostles saw that if the
Believers in galatia were saved from the
dangerous influence which threatened
them the most decisive measures must be
taken the sharpest warnings given so
it's important Martin that an important
lesson for every minister of Christ to
learn is that of adapting his labors to
the condition of Those whom he seeks to
benefit we have a whole world model that
is steeped in
Tradition and we have a whole world of
protestantism that sees no error any
longer in Catholicism no they're joining
hands now how does that make any sense
but even in the in our own church it's
also important to to adhere to this
there's a lot of apostasy it's you have
to as a minister also know how to deal
with each situation yes and as a member
you must know how to deal with those in
high
positions that think that uh
Unity with those outside of the Realms
of obedience to all of God's
Commandments seems to be The Way Forward
yeah but actually that should be rebuked
in the same way that Paul rebuked the
Galatians that's
it so
tenderness patience decision and
firmness are alike needful but these are
to be exercised with proper
discrimination to deal wisely with
different classes of Minds under various
circumstances and conditions is a work
requiring wisdom and judgment
enlightenment and Sanctified by the
spirit of
God you know I think of Solomon who
prayed for
wisdom but he also prayed for a tender
heart makes sense and uh he got his
riches as
well pity that he
later apostasis
anyway in his letter to the galatian
Believers Paul briefly reviewed the
leading incidents connecting with his
own conversion and early Christian
experience by this means he thought to
show that it was through a special
manifestation of divine power that he
had been led to see and grasp the great
truths of the
Gospel it was through instruction
received from God himself that Paul was
led to warn and admonish the Galatians
in so solemn and positive a manner he
wrote not in hesitancy and doubt but
with Assurance of settled conv
conviction and absolute knowledge he
clearly outlined the difference between
being taught by man and receiving
instructions direct from
Christ now he wrote all those things
down and we can read
them and are they being confused oh
completely Romans The Book of Romans and
Galatians for that matter didn't Peter
say Paul writes some things hard to
understand but in actual fact when you
start traveling it it's not hard to
understand it's the relationship between
law and Grace that's it you just put
that in context and if you start reading
it with with knowing that yes it's much
so if you take Romans are you saved by
keeping the law no definitely not you
are not saved by keeping the law do you
make void the law thereby no God forbid
you establish the law now you know to
many Minds that must be a cognitive
dissonance dichotomy of thinking
how can you establish something that you
can't use for salvation you see if you
understand the context yes then it makes
sense but if you just want to if your if
you elevate one an iot yeah over the
other you become confused that's it so
if you put the other before where it
should be if you want to get rid of the
law you can read Romans as getting rid
of it yes but if you want to know how to
get saved then you read that that the
law is established but not by like
you've mentioned keeping it because you
want to be saved yes but still you have
to keep it you have to keep because
nobody will be saved by keeping the law
but nobody will be saved by neglecting
the law exactly let me just make it
clear because people have a tendency to
misunderstand how I put things because
sometimes the language barrier gets in
the way yes so what I mean is you keep
the law because you're saved because you
want to keep it you don't keep it to be
saved who enables you to want to keep it
Jesus because your flesh Wass against
keeping it for
sure I was sitting in
a in a restaurant the other day I was
waiting for a
takeaway and the television was blaring
there on the
screen and
it was hard not to look at it because it
was right in front of
you and it had uh music videos on
it but they were so Lous
yeah and you think to yourself This is
what the world craves this is what it's
like this what happens in the nightclubs
right this is this is the portrayal of
what
happens and you can see there how the
flesh Wars against the law
yeah and you have to you have to thank
God that that doesn't have
power that's true because how many
people are ruined because it has power
over them but that is the norm and the
standard of the World the Flesh Wars
against righteousness and righteousness
Wars against the
flesh so
all very
interesting so he urged the Galatians to
leave the false guides by whom they had
been misled and to return to the faith
that had been accompanied by
unmistakable evidence of divine
approval The Men Who had attempted to
lead them from their belief in the
gospel were Hypocrites Unholy in heart
and corrupt in life but if you say that
to some of the modern teachers out there
they would be highly offended
yes the religion was made up of a round
of Ceremonies through the performance of
which they expected to gain the favor of
God they had no desire for a gospel that
called for obedience to the word except
the man be born again he cannot see the
kingdom of God quoting John
3:3 they felt that the religion based on
such a Doctrine required too great a
sacrifice and they clung to their errors
deceiving themselves and others to
substitute external forms of religion
for Holiness of heart and life is still
as pleasing to the unrenewed nature as
it was in the days of these Jewish
teachers today as then there are false
spiritual guides to whose doctrines many
listen
eagerly I sit and I watch them speaking
to these mega
churches and teaching a gospel of
prosperity without obedience to any of
God's requirements yeah isn't it
pathetic no it's it's sad
actually because and it's the majority
this is how it if you the minority well
Jesus said that the road is narrow and
filled with all sorts of
obstacles so it is Satan's studied
effort to divert Minds from the hope of
Salvation through faith in Christ and
obedience to the law of God in every age
the arch enemy adapts his Temptations to
the prejudices or inclinations of those
who he seeking to deceive in Apostolic
times he led the Jews to exalt the
ceremonial law and reject Christ at the
present time he induces many professing
Christians under pretense of honoring
Christ to cast contempt on the moral law
law and to teach that its precepts may
be transgressed with
impunity it is the duty of every servant
of God to withstand firmly and decided
these perverts of the faith and by the
word of Truth fearlessly to expose their
errors now Mar some of
them will expound on the virtues of the
law mhm but they neglect the fourth
Commandment yeah verily my Sabbath you
shall keep for it is a sign between me
and you
forever right yeah that I am the Lord
that sanctifies you they just brush it
aside and try to find
scriptural yeah proof for their position
when there is none so in his effort to
regain confidence of his brethren in
galatia Paul aely Vindicated his
position as an apostle of Christ
he declared himself to be an apostle not
of men neither by man but by Jesus
Christ and God the Father who raised him
from the
dead one receives a calling from God
that's it and you either obey it or you
don't it's like when you the person
called you and said that she received um
information from God that you should
finish her late husband's book yes
and she continued on and on and then you
said to her but I haven't received such
an instruction
yet so not from men but from the highest
Authority in heaven had he received his
commission and his position had been
acknowledged by a general council at
Jerusalem with the decisions of which
Paul had complied in all his labors
amongst the Gentiles it was not to exalt
self but to magnify the grace of God
that Paul Paul thus presented to those
who were denying his apostil ship proof
that he was not a wit behind the very
chiefest of the Apostles quoting 2
Corinthians those who sought to belittle
his calling and his work were fighting
against Christ whose Grace and power
were manifested through Paul the Apostle
was forced by the opposition of his
enemies to take a decided stand in
maintaining his position and Authority
Paul pleaded with those who had once
known in their lives the power of God to
return to their first love of the Gospel
truth is that our commission too that's
it we were talking about preparing for
all the things that's coming Upon Us MH
and so can we expect that these things
that happened in galatia and in Corinth
is going to happen will we expect
opposition from teachers that place
Traditions above can it happen in our
own rank oh it's I cannot it is all
right so if it can be possible to
support legislation against freedom of
conscience then surely when they make
laws negating the Commandments of God
based on their traditional concepts of
righteousness many might take their
stand on that side then you have to have
the same admonition that Paul
yeah so with
unv arguments he set before them their
privilege of becoming free men and women
in Christ through whose atoning Grace
all who make full surrender are clothed
with the robe of his righteousness this
is the bottom
line you have to embrace the
righteousness of Christ because your
righteousness is just not going to cut
it done finished so now people say
righteousness by faith negates the law
no it elevates the law yes because
because the very word righteousness
means doing what is right that's it and
if you want to be an heir just as Paul
said to the Galatians you have to obey
the law because that's the only way to
obey Christ did Christ say I have kept
the Commandments yes I have kept I've
kept them so if he kept them how did he
keep them half or perfectly perfectly he
kept them perfectly can I do I keep them
perfectly no no so whose righteousness
do I need Christ his so he must be
working in me in order for me to keep
the law perfectly that's it so I must
work in my sphere and he must work in
his sphere and that can only be done
through faith only through faith so he
took the position that every soul who
would be saved must have a genuine
personal experience in the things of God
I cannot be saved in a
group that doesn't mean I don't belong
to a group no the group is the harborer
yes of the truth and you have to be part
of it but you are saved on your
individual Choice correct the apostles
Earnest words of entreaty were not
fruitless the Holy Spirit wrought with
Mighty power and many whose feet had
wandered into strange paths returned to
their former faith in the gospel
henceforth they were steadfast in the
Liberty where with Christ had made them
free
free from what free from the
condemnation of the law correct and free
from the bondage of sin that's it in
other words you were brought back back
into harmony go and sin no
more henceforth they were steadfast in
the Liberty which Christ had made them
free in their lives were revealed the
fruits of the spirit love joy peace
longsuffering gentleness goodness Faith
meekness
Temperance so much do we have to ask our
eles do we have love for those who do
not necessarily by the standards that we
have deserve love we have to did Jesus
have love for those that didn't deserve
it yes okay
Joy is this worldly Joy or is this Joy
of being saved what is the joy of Christ
isn't the joy of Christ seeing Sinners
saved yeah are you happy when you see a
sinner saved oh for sure okay peace
even in the midst of a storm it's not
the peace and safety that the nations
are crying for and I'm so glad that
you've learned longsuffering right
Martin I'm working on that one you're
working on that one gentleness goodness
Faith meekness Temperance Temperance is
also one of those easy ones yes so the
name of God was glorified and many were
added to the number of Believers through
that region so is it is it easy no and I
was mentioning earlier that I'm working
on that but that's a wrong wording Jes I
must allow Jesus to help me work on that
you are quite right so let's go back to
Galatians now it
say that the
heir that's the one who inherits the
promise right as long as he is a child
differeth nothing from a servant though
he be Lord of all wow right but he under
tutors and governors until the time
appointed of the
father when I was very small I think I
was
about 9 or
10 we had a a border living in the house
we' taken my parents had taken in a
person that had come from overseas and
took them under his
wings and he very soon started to think
that it was his duty to govern
me I was about
10 and he laid down the rules and of
course I gladly accepted them right yeah
of course no I rebelled against them
with every Power of my being calling him
a cuss name with the word border
afterwards you're just a border who the
heck are you to try and tell me what to
do so the fact of the matter was he was
bigger and stronger than I was so I had
a hard
time but in my
eyes he was a
servant but he was lording it over me so
I was the servant so these things are
all very interesting
Martin even so when we were children we
were in bondage under the elements of
the world but when the fullness of time
was come God sent forth his son made of
a woman made under the
law well Martin there goes the dogma of
the Immaculate Conception yeah
unfortunately it belongs in the waste
paper basket according to this verse
because this woman was under the curse
of the law so she was not Immaculate
without sin yeah and how could she be
because she needed Redemption exactly
and that could only come through the
blood of Christ so what there's so much
depth in all of this to redeem them that
were under the law in other words under
the curse of the law that we might
receive the adoption of sons yeah so
becomeing AES so we become hes and
because you are Sons God has sent forth
the spirit of his son into your hearts
crying Abba
father so if I do not have the son and I
do not have the spirit of the son that
has kept every precept and is my
righteousness then I am lost the same
applies to Mary she was born under the
law the only way she could be saved is
through the blood of the
Lamb therefore Thou Art no more a
servant but a son and if a son then an
heir of God through Christ it's a it's a
beautiful Doctrine for sure of
Salvation he continues how be it then
when ye knew not God ye did service unto
them which by Nature are no Gods but now
after that you have known God or rather
are known of God it's very well put yeah
how turn ye again to the weak and
beggarly
elements where unto you desire again to
be in bondage but if you have tasted
salvation if you have tasted that the
Lord is good if you have tasted the
Redemptive power that has taken you out
of this world of sin and debuchy and
brought you to an understanding of
things that are holy and pure and just
and good why do we want to return to the
beggarly elements yeah to which we were
in bondage you want to go back to the r
seen no not at all do you have any
desire to go back does it draw you no
it's like a a dark returning to its
vomit okay well put Martin that's
biblical by the way you observe
days do we need to say
more and months and times and
years how many festivals have we had
lately which were the observance of days
and months and times and years and for a
short while they were even while they
are keeping days and times and
years they is a longing for something
better but then when that day is over
back to the grindstone and back to the
old life nothing
changes I'm afraid for you lest I have
bestowed upon you labor in vain Brethren
I beseech you be as I am for I am as ye
are ye have not injured me at all you
know how through infirmity of the flesh
I preached the gospel unto you at first
and my Temptation which was in my flesh
you despised not nor rejected but
received me as an angel of God even as
Christ Jesus so he had a thorn in his
flesh and it was there as a reminder
keep him humble yeah Martin I've got
news for
you I've got a a few
Thorns where is then the blessedness you
spake of for I bear you record that if
it had been possible you would have
plucked out your own eyes and have given
them to me so I assume there was
something seriously wrong with these
eyes well after he being blinded by
Jesus I think he kept the reminder there
yes it wasn't the same and he also said
he wrote with such large
letters you know I can identify with him
am I therefore become your enemy because
I tell you the truth they zealously
affect you but not well yay they would
exclude you that you might affect them
but it is good to be zealously affected
always in a good thing and not only when
I am present with you my little children
of whom I travail in birth again until
Christ be formed in you Christ in you
the hope of glory so but in all of these
traditions and all of these things that
the world is steep in will not save you
no you must have this relationship you
must go through the process of
repentance
acceptance and you must humble yourself
you must break yeah on the Rock what
must break what must break on the rock
all of you the old man all this your
pride must break on the rock your
jealousy must break on your rock the
hatred that you have for what ever out
there in the world must break on the
rock all of these things must break on
the Rock anything selfish anything that
you cling to anything that you think you
cannot overcome that must break on the
rock it must break it must shatter it
may never be resurrected
again I desire to be present with you
now and to change my voice for I stand
in doubt of you tell me ye that desire
to be under the law in other words under
the bondage of the law yeah you that are
trying to keep the law to be saved yes
well put do you not hear the law now is
and is in bondage with her
children for it is written that Abraham
had two sons this is a beautiful
allegory the one by a bonds made and the
other by a free
woman but he who was of the bonds woman
was born after the flesh wasn't by faith
was through his own
works but he of the free woman was by
promise which things are an allegory for
these are the two covenants the one from
Mount Si which gendereth to
bondage salvation by the law yeah which
is
agar so through my works I will save
myself yeah it actually started with
Cain yes for this AAR is Mount Si in
arabor and answers to Jerusalem which
now is and is in bondage with her
children but Jerusalem which is above is
free which is the mother of all now
people will take that and say see the
Lord is gone gone
yeah salvation by your works is gone
will not save you yeah for it is written
Rejoice thou Baron that bearest not
break forth and cry thou that travaileth
not for the desolate has many more
children than she which has a
husband so this one that is broken on
the Rock and receives by
faith has more children converted to the
gospel through their testimony that's it
now we Brethren as Isaac was are the
children of
promise but as then he that was born
after the flesh pers persecuted him that
was born after the spirit even so it is
now nothing has changed since the time
of Canan Abel no nothing up until today
it's the same the one born of the spirit
are persecuted by the other yes
nevertheless what says the scriptures
cast out the bonds woman and her son for
the son of the bonds woman shall not be
air with the son of the free woman so
then brethren we are not Children of the
bonds woman but of the free now some
take this literally and make it a racial
issue isn't it sad Martin that they
don't get it what's an allegory yeah
yeah is it literal no it's supposed to
show you in every situation how it can
pain so M we have to sail this boat
through all of these quag Meers so what
is the point of all of this
discussion the the point of the
discussion is simply this you have to
put law and
Grace Justice and mercy in the right
relationship you cannot negate Justice
at any time no I'm busy working on a
sermon at the
moment and if I can preempt a little
bit I I say in the sermon that in the
world there is a huge Cry For
Justice yeah isn't there there is on
every level there is a cry for justice
but there is no
justice if you take the war in
Gaza on either side of the Divide there
is a huge Cry For Justice exactly if you
take the issue of abuse of children and
pedy there is a huge cry for justice
if you take the
injustices that are happening in the
world even in the courts of
law there is a huge Cry For Real
Justice and some people are condemned to
prisons for 40 50 years when they were
innocent yeah and they think that a
little bit of money in the pocket will
be retribution for such a mistake thank
God God doesn't make a mistake right
thank God and then I thought thought
about myself and I think you know
everybody in the
world has the sense of
justice does that include the atheist
yeah even he wants Justice he wants
justice but will he ever get it not in
the way that he wants it no there will
never be Justice For The Atheist because
there will be no final Justice according
to him there's nothing Hereafter so he
has a cry for justice but no means of
obtaining it which is pretty ridiculous
so how do you want to live a life
campaigning for justice when your very
ideology negates Justice you will never
ever receive it so there must be a final
Gathering of people that put
law and Grace in the right
perspective Justice and
mercy so if we can come to come some
conclusion in this
matter would you agree Martin that the
final Gathering commences after the end
of the longest Prophecy in the Bible yes
the 2300 day prophecy after which there
would be time no more yeah now that
doesn't mean that the world has come to
an end but prophetic time has come to an
end now that prophecy ends in 1844
yeah so after
1844 there would be no more prophetic
time only prophetic
events so the final movement to come out
of the church in the wilderness would be
those that keep the Commandments of God
and hold to the testimony of Jesus is
that
biblical Revelation 12 and 14 they would
preach the Three Angels messages and
Herald the universal final loud cry so
there is no other movement to come after
this as the loud CED culminates in the
second coming of Christ would you agree
with that it's a it's a final movement
since 18 nothing else no no can't be
okay so if we quote acts of the Apostle
page 163 God has made his church on
earth a Channel of light and through it
he communicates his purposes and his
will he does not give to one of his
servants an experience erience
independent of and contrary to the
experience of the church
itself even Paul MH was given the
instruction to go to a certain place and
he would be told what to do by by the
church yes Jesus after appearing to him
personally send him back to the church
yes neither does he give one man a
knowledge of his will for the entire
church while the church Christ's body is
left in
darkness so if he gives light to someone
let's say a prophet that light has to be
disseminated to the
church and the prophets were for the
church in his Providence he places his
servants in close connection with his
church in order that they may have less
confidence in themselves and greater
confidence in others whom he's leading
out to advance his
work so God has a church that's it he
has a quote from testimonies to the
church that which Brother D calls light
is apparently harmless it does not look
as though anyone could be injured by it
but Brethren it is Satan's device he's
entering wedge this has been tried again
and again one accepts some new and
original idea which does not seem to
conflict with the truth he talks of it
and dwells upon it until it seems to him
to be clothed with beauty and importance
for Satan has power to give this false
appearance at last it becomes the all
absorbing theme the one great Point
around which everything centers and the
truth is uprooted from the heart so Mar
is it possible that within the church
yeah brother A and B or C or
D can start harboring or can start
harping on one particular aspect which
is not wrong necessarily in
itself but detracts from the message
that has to be given to the world in the
time we live in for sure and it's we see
that happening all the time if you look
at the example of Daniel 11 and Daniel
12 the King of the North and South it's
not a Salvation issue but it when
dwelling and letting it absorb all your
time it can become a problematic thing
all right so any other Doctrine whatever
it is one particular thing that
fascinates you anything that detracts
from the mission which is the Three
Angels messages at the
moment uh can happen in the church do I
then leave the church because of it no
no you try like Paul to correct the
situation and if they don't want to
listen well then eventually God will
make another plan
yeah so in other words Martin when men
arise claiming to have a message from
God but instead of Waring against
principalities and powers and the rulers
of Darkness of this world they form a
hollow square and turn their weapons of
warfare against the church
militant be afraid of
them now does this mean that you may not
correct wrongs within the church no
that's exactly not what it means tell
the house of Jacob their sins that's it
so you may do that you're not turning
your weapons against the church if you
point out these apostasies no when
you're standing outside screaming that
the church is
apostate then you have a problem and the
church actually might be apostate no but
the fact that you've removed yourself
from the church means that you have
separated from the body they do not bear
the Divine credentials God has not given
them any such burden of
Labor they would tear down that which
God would restore by the louan message
this is very interesting Martin so the
louan message is stop being
lukewarm so can we just make it clear
because we've had how many accusations
that you said that we should stay in the
church and we should stay in L the
lisian state uh the rebuke to the church
is to come out of the Lan state so in
other words Martin
the Lord lays upon no man a message that
will discourage and dishearten the
church he reproves he rebukes he
chastens but it is only that he may
restore and approve at last so we have
to wait for God to bring about a
shaking so the Lord lays upon us the
message to encourage people to show out
these things but like you mentioned it's
he that will do the restoring and all of
this otherwise I judge things before the
time right how glad my heart was made by
the report from the general conference
that many hearts were softened and
subdued that many made humble
confessions and cleared away from the
door of the heart the rubbish that was
keeping the Savior out how glad I was to
know that many welcomed Jesus as an
abiding guest Martin who am I to judge
whether that will happen in some
individuals or whether it won't leave
that to
God how is it that these pamphlets
denouncing the Seventh Day Adventist
Church as Babylon was scattered abroad
everywhere at the very time when that
church was receiving the outpouring of
the spirit of God how is it that men can
be so deceived as to imagine that the
loud cry consists in calling the people
of God out from The Fellowship of a
church that is enjoying a season of
refreshing oh May these deceived Souls
come into the current and receive the
blessings and be endued with power from
on high this is be very painful to many
people yeah now I'm not saying that this
church is currently receiving the
blessing and I've been very firm in
saying you can pray until your knees are
raar if you don't change your Cor course
you are praying in vain that's if you
don't remove yourself from the lorded
Sean state if you don't buy gold refined
in the fire which is the righteousness
of Christ which is made manifest by
obedience to all that He commands which
includes not only the Ten Commandments
but all the other issues including
Health reform
besides then once you have clear clean
that house up and you go on your knees
and pray for the outpouring of the Holy
Spirit which will be given to them that
obey him yeah then you can expect it to
happen even within the church even with
within and if you don't adhere or do all
of those things then God will do the
shaking
yeah again I say the Lord had not spoken
by any messenger who calls the church
that keeps the Commandments of God
Babylon true there are tears with the
wheat but Christ said he would send his
Angel to First gather the tears and bind
them in bundles to burn them but gather
the wheat into the Garner I know that
the lord loves his church it is not to
be disorganized or broken up into
independent atoms there's not the least
consistency in this there's not the
least evidence that such a thing will be
those who will heed this false message
and try to leave others will be deceived
and prepared to receive Advanced
delusions and they will come to North
there is in some of the members of the
church Pride
self-sufficiency stubborn unbelief and a
refusing to re yield their ideas
although evidence may be piled upon
evidence which makes the message to the
loudan church applicable but that will
not blot out the church that it will not
exist let both tears and wheat grow
together until the Harvest then it is
the angels that do the work of
Separation Martin I cannot because I see
apostasy
run because there's nothing after this
even
Paul the apostasy Who made did the
apostasy after the Jerusalem Council
the leadership yes did Paul leave the
church because of that no he did
not so the church is the light of the
world although there are evils existing
in the church and will be until the end
of the world the church in these last
days is to be the light of the world
that is polluted and demoralized by sin
the church enfeebled and defective
needed to be reproved warned and
counseled
is the only object upon Earth upon which
Christ bestows his Supreme
regard wow Martin that is an amazing
statement it's a powerful and strong yes
the world is a workshop in which through
the cooperation of human and divine
agencies Jesus is making experiments by
his grace and divine mercy upon human
hearts angels are amazed as that behold
the transformation of character brought
about in those who yield themselves to
God and they express their joy in songs
of rapturous praise to God and to the
lamb they see those who are by Nature
the children of WTH converted and
becoming laborers together with Christ
in drawing souls to God do we have those
also in the
church do we have the apostates in the
church
yes they see though those who were in
darkness becoming lights to shine amidst
the moral night of this wicked and
perverse generation they see them
becoming prepared by a Christlike
experience to suffer with their lord and
afterwards to be partakers with him in
glory in Heaven above so where
is most of the juggling taking place
outside or inside inside inside
definitely is it a painful experience
for sure but maybe we can give some
advice If instead of getting pulled into
all this conflict in the church if you
focus on bringing the Three Angels
messages to the people outside then this
won't take up so much of your time no
you won't have time for it and then when
you bring the people in you warn them
that this is not a perfect place you
tell them yes and once you've given the
warning that's it you don't have to give
it over and over and over and over again
and you don't have to play policemen to
see that everybody does it if they don't
want to do it that's their business and
you carry on with the Commission carry
on with the commission so the third
angel of Revelation 14 is represented as
flying swiftly through the midst of
Heaven crying here are they that keep
the Commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus here is shown the nature of the
work of the people of God they have a
message of so great importance that they
are represented as flying in the
presentation of it to the world they are
holding in their hands the bread of life
for a famishing world the love of Christ
constraineth them this is the last
message there's no more to follow no
more invitation of Mercy to be given
after this message shall have done its
work what a trust what a responsibility
is resting upon all to carry the words
of gracious
invitation and the spirit and the bride
say come and let him that heareth say
come and let him that is The Thirst come
and whoever will let him that take the
Water of Life freely now here's a very
important
Point Christ does
nothing apart from his church it says
over there the spirit and the bride yes
say come but many people say I don't
want the bride I only want the spirit
you can't have the one without the the
other so the Lord has declared that the
history of the past shall be rehearsed
as we enter upon the closing work every
truth that he has given for these last
days is to be proclaimed to the world
every pillar that he has established is
to be strengthened not torn down
Martin we cannot now step off the
foundation that God has established we
cannot now enter into to any new
Organization for this would mean
apostasy from the
truth I hope that the spirit of Prophecy
is
clear sometimes it's so clear that
people don't want to adhere so they try
to get rid of it all right so if the
truth has once been established no
matter how you tear at that
Foundation it has been established it is
there so when the power of God testifies
as to what is truth
that truth is to stand forever as the
truth no after suppositions contrary to
the light that God has given are to be
entertained do that mean they won't be
entertained no unfortunately they will
as long as there is a devil they will be
entertained that's it men will arise
with interpretations of scripture which
are to them truth but which are not
truth the truth for this time God has
given us as a foundation for our faith
he himself has taught us what is truth
one will arise and still another with
new light which contradicts the light
that God has given under the
demonstration of the Holy Spirit we have
leaders that say what we believe is 19th
century delusion that's why I say they
want to get rid of the spirit of
Prophecy because it doesn't fit in with
what they want to believe I don't care
what they say do you care what they say
no because truth will stay truth yes and
some of them have done this publicly and
some of them I've even answered publicly
and they will not get me to move and I
probably won't get them to move but
that's not the issue do I now leave the
church because these people were church
leaders no no I pity them that's it pray
for them a few are still alive who
passed through the experience gained in
the establishment of those truth
God has graciously spared their lives to
repeat and repeat till the close of
their lives The Experience through which
they passed even as did John the Apostle
till the very close of his life and the
standard bearers who have fallen in
death are to speak through the
reprinting of their writings I am
instructed that thus their voices are to
be heard they are to Bear the testimony
as to what constitutes the truth for
this time now let me just make another
Point here here Martin
M because these standard
bearers were involved in the
proclamation of these truths does that
mean they understood all the truths no
or must we still filter what they said
through the scriptures and the testimony
of course okay so whatever has been said
in the past is not necessarily gospel
unless it is in harmony with the Bible
and the spirit of Prophecy it was
most of the times actually but probably
all of the time acknowledged through the
spirit of Prophecy correct or they
changed their opinions that can so if
you read an early opinion maybe you
should compare it with a later opinion
that's always very important
always and the church is made up of
saints yeah and then sometimes even
people that had the truth strayed from
that later on correct and even if there
are Saints within this
church the Bible says all have sinned
and come short of the glory of God all
of us are in need of divine grace all of
us need to buy gold refined in the fire
nobody but nobody is exempt from that so
let us rather remain humble and
acknowledge that we are as much in need
of the grace of God as those who are
blatantly
apostate and let us pray for each other
and let's stick together and let me
reiterate by
superglue stick with it and wait till
God cleans up the ship and then when the
loud cry comes we will know who was on
the Lord's Side but in the meanwhile
don't sit and do
nothing give the message go and preach
the three give the message preach the
message let's
pray Heavenly Father this subject has to
be agitated over and over and over
again and I I understand Lord that this
war will wage until the last
day but please Lord Enlighten minds and
like Paul send them to those
that are the
representatives of your Truth for the
times we are living in is my prayer in
Jesus name amen
[Music]
amen